normalement le comice agricole c'est
festif c'est l'occasion de montrer la
vitalité du monde agricole à briare le
mal être de ce monde agricole était
perceptible jusque dans les discours de
ses représentants qui ont tiré à boulet
rouge sur les spéculateurs le laxisme
des politiques et la grande distribution
je veux qu'on sort et agriculture mais
il faut aussi mettre tous ensemble
enfin le monde qui nous gouvernent en
prennent conscience
pour nourrir à bon marché eh bien on
importe de la viande allemande qui est
beaucoup moins cher parce que moi normes
parce que des exploitations de plus
grande dimension parce que dans les
abattoirs on emploient de la main
d'oeuvre polonaise turc qui est payé à 6
euros de l'heure
parmi les exposants deux éleveurs de
vaches seulement ont fait le déplacement
inimaginable dans un comice agricole est
encore l'un d'eux fait de la vente
directe et se maintient en activité
grâce aux revenus de son épouse j'arrive
pas à me dégager de salaire
heureusement qu'on est poussé à
l'extérieur mais la bande de bêtes et
tous et pour prier les crédits payer les
charges baigner tout ce qui est appuyé
dans l'exportation
interpellé par les responsables
agricoles le président de région qui a
pris parti contre la grande distribution
s'est engagée à convaincre les
responsables des cantines acheter
français
je veux que donc tout les restaurants
scolaires ils puissent avoir un choix
qui fasse une place très très très
particulière à la production locale à la
production nationale en matière de lait
en matière de viande c'est possible dans
le cadre des marchés publics
nous allons réunir l'ensemble des
décideurs pour engager ce mouvement à
l'échelle de notre région mais un comice
agricole ne serait pas conforme à la
coutume sans le traditionnel concours de
labour qui réunissait cette année une
vingtaine de participants
et pour ceux qui voulaient avoir un
aperçu de ce qu'on peut encore trouver
dans une ferme
une exposition constituée d'une
vingtaine d'animaux domestiques que
fabrice et valérie ont sauvé de la
maltraitance